Casey Johnson kind enough to join us
he's got a lot to write about here
he's the beat writer for the Chicago
Tribune and his most recent article is
we're moving on Jim Boylan and his
players meet to build trust
after the Bulls historic loss when did
this mess start Casey well that depends
on who you talk to Dan obviously the
coaching change for was made last week
from Fred Hoiberg to Jim Boylan and
management at that time talked about
needing more accountability talked about
needing a better culture so management
might have a tant one answer for that as
far as where the current mess started it
started really from the first day Jim
Boylan took over from Fred Hoiberg Jim
Boylan not only is coaching to his true
personality but also feels emboldened by
a mandate an organizational mandate
given to him by ownership and management
to change the culture and so he is being
confrontational he's being direct he's
being tough he's demanding a lot of
players and those players push back late
Saturday night with talk of a possible
boycott of Sunday's practice which
ultimately never materialized but as you
mentioned gave us plenty to write about
okay the biggest issue they have is but
being pushed too hard well the biggest
issue they have is they're not a very
good basketball team let's start there
obviously they're in the second season
of a full rebuild following the June
2017 Jimmy Butler trade they've been
incredibly injured you know critical
core players Chris Dunn Bobby Portis
Laurie Markin and Denzel Valentine were
all out marketing has since come back
Portis and Dunn returned last night so
let's start there there they're not a
good team they're also a young team they
don't know how to win in the NBA they're
trying to navigate a full rebuild and
they're not obviously healthy so that
does not help matters and then you know
they obviously with the coaching change
that was a tumultuous situation they
enjoyed playing for Fred Hoiberg he's a
player friendly coach he it gives
players a lot of freedom and Jim's got a
very different style and you know
was the associate head coach it's not
like they don't know him but as we all
know when you move from that had you
know one chair over from the lead
assistant to the head coach you're in a
different role now and players not all
players not all players but obviously
some players are initially chasing at
that approach who's the leader of this
team uh well you know when you're
talking about a young basketball team
that would be determined I mean
obviously you'd like it to be one of
your core players that you're building
around like a Zach Lavine or Al Ahram
are kind but those are young guys trying
to figure it out Zach took a very vocal
role in that team meeting so that's
probably a good sign you've got the sage
old veteran Robin Lopez who you know
doesn't play as much anymore but it
seemed a little bit of everything in his
decade plus in the NBA so he's obviously
helped navigate this situation a little
bit and look I know this has create a
lot of headlines and a lot of talk which
is why I'm speaking to you and it's fun
but I will say that you know the team is
in a better place
moving from Saturday night to Sunday
night I mean if you're firing off a
group text exchanged talking about
boycotting practice and then ultimately
you have a two-hour team meeting and
guys are yelling at each other and
getting everything out in the open you
can't help but be in a better place now
it's just obviously got to take hold on
the basketball court
yeah but Chicago is famous for having
tough coaches here so I'm guessing the
fan base is probably going to be on the
side of Jim Boylan is that would that be
fair to say well I mean you know he's
unproven I mean you know in a lot of
ways it's funny because you talk about a
two decade plus career assistant who's
getting his first chance that seems to
bring it to my mind the name Tom
Thibodeau but he's certainly not as
accomplished early as Tom Thibodeau Tom
Thibodeau 162 games and its first season
albeit with a much better roster you
know you say the day I've had tough
coaches and they've had they they have
but you know no Jack you said there was
legs crossed when they won six
championships all time odd he also had
Michael Jordan Scottie Pippen out
everything around the forms for that
that held things but under this
managerial regime of John Paxson and gar
form and Danny's gone they've kind of
gone back and forth John Paxson
inherited
car right from Jerry Krause Scott Skiles
more of a taskmaster then they moved to
Vinny Del Negro more of a player
friendly than they would be Tom
Thibodeau tough-minded then they moved
to Fred Hoiberg Clair friendly and now
they're back to Jim Boylan it's the
age-old adage in sports you kind of
swing the pendulum and go the other way
so they were gonna boycott practice and
then reportedly a couple of players went
to the Players Association to kind of
tattle on their coach to say and maybe
tattle is not the right word but they
were they were saying look this is
what's going on after back-to-back games
and now we have a two-hour practice here
yeah right well yeah Yahoo Sports first
important event I was able to
dependently confirm that I believe there
was one maybe two players and look
there's not a lot the Players
Association can do except listening and
pat him on the back it's not like Jim
Boylan was you know doing anything
incredibly untoward I will say he's
being he has been unconventional I mean
then the second practice that that he
held not only did it go to NASA hours he
then bragged to us you know meagher beat
writers about all the wind sprints he
made the broad I mean this is not
typical stuff particularly in December
you know I mean maybe in September
you're hearing stuff like that from
coaches but not really in December he's
also having them do push-ups watch
showed them film clips in the direct
aftermath of his first game of coach a
loss at Indiana a six-point loss you
broke out the film right there in the
post game locker room so players are
just kind of you know it's a different
role for Jim they're trying to figure
out Jim Jim's trying to figure out a
Steve and off we go as they as they lose
basketball games yeah I was just
wondering why not keep Hoiberg in there
let him run out the string be a bad team
get a high draft pick and then make a
coaching change here
well management directly answered that
question and particularly taking your
logic and and which is one that I was
subscribing to as well particularly when
they're about to get healthy Fred
Hoiberg on Lorimar cannon for one game
Chris Dunn and Bobby Portis has returned
were on the horizon they came back last
night over to Jim Boylan so Fred Hoiberg
was clearly coaching and working on the
impression
he was gonna at least get a chance with
a healthy roster management directly
question about that dynamic said the
fundamental problems they were seen
would not have been masked by a bump or
a win streak by players returning to the
rotation so they saw some pretty
fundamental issues which is exactly what
I'm talking about here were not only is
Jim Boylan coaching to his true
personality he's doing so emboldened by
this organizational mandate he feels he
has free rein to coach this way mandated
by management and even more importantly
by ownership so this could be bumpy over
these next 50 games Jim is acknowledged
as such and we'll see how it plays out
Thank You Casey we appreciate your time
good luck Casey Johnson he's a Bulls
beat writer Chicago Tribune for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]